alemania prioriza su protección en
materia energética de cara a un invierno
que se anuncia difícil el gobierno del
canciller olaf scholz puso bajo tutela
de estado al grupo ruso rosneft lo que
significa que berlín se apodera de las
actividades de las filiales de la
compañía en alemania para asegurar el
suministro de gasolina diesel y
combustible de aviación rosner dos
länder representa el 12 por ciento de la
capacidad de refinación de petróleo del
país la tutela entró en vigor el viernes
16 de septiembre y está prevista para
seis meses
esta es una decisión de política
energética de gran alcance para proteger
a nuestro país como descubrimos hace
mucho tiempo rusia ya no es un proveedor
de energía confiable con esta nueva
medida se asegura que alemania recibirá
petróleo a medio y largo plazo el
canciller se dijo estar preparado ante
una posible retaliación rusa con la
decisión las autoridades podrán asegurar
el funcionamiento y abastecimiento de
tres plantas de rousseff en alemania no
es la primera vez que berlín aplica
acciones similares en abril se tomó la
misma medida con gazprom germanía
también filial de la gigante rusa del
gas natural por su parte rosneft
respondió a la medida mediante un
comunicado a remitiendo contra la
decisión alemana y sin descartar la vía
legal
esta decisión es ilegal y de hecho es
una expropiación de la participación
accionaria como resultado de una
situación creada deliberadamente por las
sanciones pertinentes de la unión
europea y las acciones de los
reguladores alemanes y polacos cuyo
objetivo era embargar activos alemania
se ha comprometido ante la unión europea
a dejar de depender del petróleo ruso de
igual manera
a los préstamos a las empresas
energéticas que se vean afectadas por el
aumento de los precios del gas tras el
corte total del flujo del gasoducto nord
stream 1 por parte de moscú